hello and welcome to another edition of
play the people today it is
international master Dorsett Derek Shani
thank people and I'm joining you my name
is Caleb dead meat and we'll be playing
some viewers today so please head on
over to leave chess send us a challenge
at st. Louis chess club that is our lead
chess account and we'll play some chess
oh we have some I'm not sure Aaron are
they supposed to do rate it or just
casual or it's whatever you want to do
interest so speaking of any favorite
time controls rated are underrated
what do you think already accepted
appendage is an dich all right yeah but
yeah preferably maybe two seconds
increments okay we'll increment let's
see how this one turns up hello YouTube
chat room hello Omega low Omega low
hello MA L jhemini and hassan al-banna
from bangladesh all right this is one of
my favorite opening so I better remember
appearance yeah oh actually this I
played it wrong in pants rights always
yeah last time I one of the main lines
though right I played a drunk again he
said I have to play my first thank you
[Music]
so the problem is if he took with this
other nights then I can't play e5
anymore and the better move is to play
d5 and even though it looks like I got
something
yeah the game I had in penance I thought
I was bitter and but it was equal and I
pushed too far and yeah well it's really
just collapsed there was on like E 6f Oz
but again my pawn was on d5 in that game
right you get any fight this game though
yeah yeah let's see what do we want to
take a big fan of of details that's what
I'm thinking but if I if this works then
I couldn't maybe push really some e 6 D
6 it is I don't see it working right f
takes Knight g4 g 6o just easy sex
immediately okay but yeah but when I do
long cast the short yeah so then my rook
will have this wraps alright let's see
how this works okay very tempted we're
going might fail miserably
there's always that chance hello
Christos and David once again send us a
challenge only chess we are playing the
people you are the people and we're
playing alright 94 o committed at this
point yeah you're in if you're in you're
in
yeah I've done that play that people
there weren't them ladies play that
people yeah um that's a few times I
didn't have to talk as much all right
Perry I think it's bringing me some
coffee 3 p.m. afternoon coffee yes
please everybody
um surprise me
alright let's see how this might play it
out this looks very tempting
alright okay night on g4 is attacked
yeah that's I think that's kind of like
the key feature because if this night
doesn't attack maybe I don't know about
like castles or something tonight takes
me six I might've to I mean it could be
a bloody battle probably seems like it
it might be might be working out for it
for right here my say it is my
calculation so it was scary maybe yeah I
don't think you just don't have time to
do anything with quietly you about to
pick on d4 in some manner but well
that's six and G for both Bing hanging
makes yeah even if you take it's right
now I can just take Queen takes g4 and
then I just take Queen e6 and I'm doing
this little guy over here the thing that
should be what if I played night I've -
oh my god he did I'm thinking like a
1600 that's great thank you very much
pleasure so now if you take maybe I mean
I have to yeah maybe he's intending the
castle to check and then try and take
this d4 pawn and sacrifice a piece like
this gotta tell ya I like boys chances
up a piece seems good who's your
favorite chess player Fabiano Carvalho
or Dingley red well he gave us two
options but I don't know if you have a
favorite chess player other than one of
those two
oh come on free night take it what are
you thinking about I don't like it on
the opponent has so much compensation oh
you're fine more nights no I I don't
like that move to see ya castle today me
too
but see the problem is I can like try
and go tie this in the East reals do
that don't go cuz it's my plan Oh yo
chef yousa I don't know that does sound
like a right pronunciation Yousef all
right I love it I love it I can't really
see the name though but why oh you see
EF yeah I think that should be you soon
I trust it so favorite chess players
dorsa good I mean personality-wise our
game boys both overall the best I don't
know no thing we're in but the puppies
always so nice friendly smiling I agree
I also his the king of the club yes sir
I got to pick him up from the airport
one time Wow
which is very exciting for me I tell
everybody about it and how mean Bobby on
her best friends now haha
he told me about his flight and how he
watched the new Chucky movie that was
what we talked about so yeah he's a
pretty personable guy
I'm just gonna take it slow I don't want
to give to my chances get it over there
yeah I don't think customer shy before
but then there's this Bishop e5 and if I
take then the Queen comes to the game
and I prefer the Queen to stay far just
King edge three and sure you're pretty
sheltered okay so pretty sheltered
ninety six is still a threat three new
friends ladies six bonds I don't think
there is a threat just come out to
already yeah oh I like rookie one here
just really make sure this key six pawn
guys my rookie one there might be this
check and then g4 will just just queen
g4 right all right we are going to go
with your otherwise I love it
thank you David's favorite players
Carolina and now the world knows
I mean you don't really know that much
about sting real thing Willie ran so I
feel like if he knew more about him as a
person
could be a competition nah I hate him
well team Bobby that is true
speaking of that's what that's the
question who's your pick to win the
candidates other than Bobby other than
Bobby who do you think is gonna be gonna
be up there in second place third place
their lives there are some wait there
just to double-check is that Russian kid
at Cinco swing he's he's in I think I
like Cinco these nomads third to fifth
you give him third to fish yeah so one
of the underdogs the the Russian wild
yeah it's always nice to see you there
wild cards do nice see who else is in
this thing one huh who uh new qualified
from the Grand Prix it's like walking
out right ah I think so one of the azeri
guys also resemble for a moment Gareth I
think was Reginald Raja Bob's in I think
let's find out well I'm getting
presidential candidates
my time I mean four times
thank you thank you looking very fancy
so yeah we got Bobby Cara want a team or
reg Bob ding lauren wang hao alex
Grichuk young Deponia she uh nice Gary
and I like Sanka sand go I don't know
how to say his name either but nicer
yeah so so long how is the the other
kind of surprise in this list of players
this will be interesting to see how he
does
where's he's like he's better I want to
take that first he's one of like the
longest staying Chinese players up at
the top right hello uncle yeah oh yeah
yeah I mean you see a lot of like
Chinese players coming gerson they they
kind of drift off after after they hit
like 25 or something but the long has
been up there yeah see how it's kind of
hoping for bits more out of this game
but it's got kind of messy honestly
oh I mean you've got more bishops just
gotta go fast gotta go that's not really
my strong go fast take it go take it c4
go no my pawns my lovely lovely pawns
my god aah oh my god
No
well never in doubt yeah this is who got
complicated
yeah but it was interesting okay let's
see Kyle thinks neppo has a good shot in
the candidates it's interesting see what
time control do you do you want yeah oh
my god we've already got 13 challenges
anyways um I think something with
increments by a 3-2 is good 5 2 is good
3 - 5 - all right I love it I saw it 3 -
ok yeah I don't know I'm interested to
see how long how does good for a nipple
it's really one of the determining
factors will be how he starts like if he
starts pretty strong then well yeah yeah
I think that was one of those players
who when he's on Form he does really
really well but sometimes he just he
doesn't really doesn't show up to give
his best performance I started looking
at this for four nights and I mean why
not okay
so yeah I'd this Lopez if like Spanish
was played with g6 I saw some nice games
that was quite a while ago in top
tournaments and I decided to go for it
so what's the points why put the bishop
on g7 I'm gonna try and play f5 go for
the jugular sometimes it works nicely
sometimes it doesn't but in this I think
it's actually mites I mean it would be
the it would work better if the center
was closed right the bishop on who seven
does just keep an eye on TV
which is kind of nice oh I have another
idea another idea crazy
pin to win yeah we'll see I don't know
if I want after h3 maybe I'll take my
dish too
just uh okay i'ma say Justin 94 it looks
looks kind of killing yeah let's push
that's game over so this I think a lot
of beginner games actually kind of end
like this this is a trick that I've seen
kind of teaching class that gets me be
done yeah where the Fisher comes out to
g4 g5 and then you know everybody plays
this a 45 system when they're first
starting out and and things like 94 can
sometimes just be devastating ya know
overall I like this kind of even though
the bishop here might look a little
weird whoa pretty long you just just
doing what you're doing
you know making it work
see how this pays off the only thing
that I kind of have to be well not in
this specific situation but there isn't
like some checks here and then you take
back there's some stuff like that but
not in this position okay
so yeah those are some stuff to look out
for Queen f6 is coming yeah
so this is why you see players usually
not not so hasty to allow things like
ninety four and so when you play things
like d3 you have to be really careful
yeah you're blocking off the bishop can
come make to eat you if you need exactly
yeah gotta solve this problem of the pen
so like the thing is instead of this d3
maybe something like h3 could be
preventative I like it it's too late now
though yeah well now like h5 and h4 and
the bishop stress talking point for the
jugular yeah it's it's over it's over
how to play well no you got a do oh it's
click the link that's somebody else
posted I'm not logged in so I can't give
you the link and then challenge us to I
guess 3 plus 2 or 5 plus 2 whatever you
want something something with a
two-second increment and we might click
a challenge huh your bishops attacks I
see that okay just make you thank you
thank you
which one to take oh my god your bishops
attacked and you're not gonna move it
see it's incredible intermediate lose
this is high class chess thank you thank
you no your bishops attacked twice
[Music]
it's push-push time
what's so uh in in these 45 systems
you'll see stuff like this when one side
kind of castles too early so how do you
know when's the right moment to castle
with with white or black or when should
you be cautious
I don't think fast though was like.he
like she I don't think Castle was too
early but the thing is like here I'm not
attacking the center after g6 so they
think d4 is the main move to consider
bishop on c4 looks nice because it's
attacking the supposedly weak Khan but
okay see you like here if I play Knight
f6 there's this 95 tricky so but here I
don't think Castle was too early
probably d3 was too early because this
is gonna be a strategic game so I'm not
really showing which side I want to
castle but I'm more more ready to cast
it on the Kings side so if white plays
something like d4 and started trying to
open the center I have to quickly castle
and short castle would be my kind of
escape
okay broke yeah escape so working my own
versions everybody looks interesting
someone bad someone good guy says same
physics I like the name see it doesn't
have increments
alright this physics 5 oh I survived
like summer physics
have this that's an interesting question
who is the strongest woman chess player
in America for the moment I think it's
probably still Irina crush as it has
been for a long long time it's almost
been like well it's for a long time it's
been between em Irina and Anton ski but
speaking of that in the future keep an
eye out because Carissa yep is actually
making some pretty serious rating gains
as is current US Women's Champion
Jennifer yuh yeah and so the youngsters
are coming you might want to be on the
lookout for those two especially coming
up in the Karin's Cup here I don't think
the players list is just yet officially
announced but keep an eye out there
might be some surprise new faces to look
forward to in that tournament oh and we
have we have published it so I can just
say Carissa yep is playing in the 2020
Cairns Cup so she'll be playing the best
in the world she's got sure I'm not
mistaken she got her title rights I have
no idea
last I heard she was she was still not
yet in an IM maybe she i know some of
the girls got I entitled recently I
thought Jennifer did I don't know
Jennifer you yeah I thought there were
two of them good might have been wrong
let's find out
ah yeah she got it in the spice Cup
every year or last year now
how old is she 14 15 she's 16 I was 16
to 18 was my few years
ah okay what are you trying to do and
friends
you gotta give this a try seems kind of
weird but yes this is kind of the
nonchalant way playing against the
nimzo-indian or why just kind of
develops all all of the pieces and
doesn't doesn't try too hard to prove
something well I'm trying to do I have
nothing to prove just want my pieces out
it's not a bad way to play chess
thank you
okay bye-bye mighty all right now I got
some stuff to work on over here
I've always thought things like Queen c7
and E 5 okay yeah those are let's see 7
or E so that's well I like c7 you keep
an eye on that c4 pollen and you step
out any Bishop c5 stuff later on all
right I listened to last game and it
turned out we'll see how close this
thing is I take all the credit
planets all the credit all right you
want to come here well you can't do that
where you trying to go my friends this
Conan is still around in the st. Louis
area doing some stuff with us huh yeah
yeah coming up in later in February
actually is gonna be G Monroe's vets so
keep an eye out for some more of our
lectures in the very near future near
future
yeah if I had a rook here then I would
actually have traits of attacking this
directly but now I have to specially six
I haven't played in like this in years
this is nice stuff this is
[Music]
see car pop games yeah yeah yeah way
back in the day this is how this is how
muscle South Louisville their I don't
know what is what I wear my big puffy
jackets I'm like sweating and burning I
take that up and put on a normal one and
my ears are freezing
this is years off it's real tough
alright this seems to be going well
maybe like I'd like to move the effort
right so I'm out of this Alice Bishop on
83 yeah that to say I'm a little scared
to move that because if I move to tear
there might be some Sun Bishop of trees
coming up okay okay let's go attack this
little guy right here 27 yeah faster
Beth Deacon comes into our studio raids
our fridge takes our alcohol and then
just goes up says bye unbelievable I
can't believe it physics
how much longer is the stream that's a
good question I have no idea me neither
I go into a coma stop that's mostly
usually these probably it's usually
works like another hour all right sounds
about right
can you win this pawn yet no but take
you six back the pond Oh
huh well there's this master 95f cares
smooth clean maybe you care I do
yeah it's a shame life's easy really
don't care
I know all right let's just say listen
if this dream
what sillas on slipstream is he
listening that's okay I'm sure why I
mean technically I could take years on
any place before that was a better idea
I mean she'd for three would be nice I
should have done that oh there's my mmm
yeah I would have been better I didn't
take my own advice I didn't sprout
Boyd's takes enough who needs
calculation
you're gonna very chill up today
am i yeah I just goes a little people
you know I'll try sword one you know
some fun all right so now maybe you can
just like get in get in get in there
trying to bring my rook what is so funny
I don't know what's the there can save
in your key five Kage 5 5 likes
I would love my position oh come on I'll
kick my clean out just yes h3 tax the
Queen makes weaknesses though not so
simple
hmm I like my coin thing easy to solve
all these problems maybe it's time for
some some pawn pushes yeah it's five
it's coming up a low-crime my student
thank you there it goes it was only a
matter of time
can't keep that pond forever
technically could but you can try but
then all your pieces are stuck in the
Queen's yep
that is thirds okay now do you want to
get that the bishop over the knight t59
third mission Knights Knights
whatever son finally it's a locking it
in
I want my bishop on d3 is this your
first time playing the people I the
official yeah of course you play the
play that or you're a part of ladies
play the people on Thursdays and you and
I have been doing some pro chesley
commentary on Mondays so definitely not
new to the stream but new to the plate
of people show okay tonight that is just
because you said so so you're gonna be
right I've got all the power love it
Bishop do you think III let's keep it
like this it feels so nice everything it
was like tangled up okay I don't have
all the Valerie I might nice to step out
for two minutes you could play I love
playing chess well my favorite board are
you going man oopsie no one told the
same physics the value of the pieces he
did not about because he did it was my
bad very tricky guy right thank you it's
my professional recommendation to go
Queens attacks gotta move the Queen have
time take bishop
waits waiting upon the Queen f6 gets the
Queen's off the board trying to be pond
and the C pawn will end the game
if this doesn't win I don't know it just
the bishop controls b11 it's all good B
5 B 4 B 3 wait a second yeah well that
was the right order to say those numbers
and there goes the rock
WAPA and now comes the Queen resigns
alright
game over good to take the next match
I'll be back in Ghent absolutely okay
okay throw it
we've been dodging this 23.94 guy for a
while
all right
Hojo see what we got here take it over
just play all the same opening so I like
it I like it big F three names of fan
myself really he's even playing the
right move orders it's incredible
nobody ever plays the right move orders
so this opening wins by force for white
at least when I play it
what's the jacket the guy is wearing
it's a chess club exclusive you can't
have it
why are me five hundred US dollars and
I'll send it to you there's my favorite
world champion of all time I don't know
maybe this one probably not this one no
I know the next one that's my favorite
world champion of all time
f4 is not the main line he's trying to
kill me and I respect it you know f4 is
not not the normal way of going about
things but you know if the guy wants
blood and he wants blood I wish him the
best this is this is abnormal I'm gonna
take
he takes like this but now 96 am I gonna
get killed
am I gonna get killed you have to tell
me if I'm gonna get killed
I think I'm gonna get killed I don't
want to get killed that sounds not fun
however I think I have a trick do I have
a trick I always do it it's fun all
right coach joke are you gonna try to
kill me
mm-hmm I dare you I dare you to take my
h7 pawn he won't he's too scared it's
too scared of my trick nobody knows what
my trick is nobody knows I'm gonna take
it you're gonna take it we'll see we'll
see if he takes it
everybody knows the Greek gift come on
it's so simple King g8 Queen h5 I'm
checkmated I'm just checkmated dude you
got me Doris is back all right we're
doing great I want to finish this game
though because oh my God he's so afraid
of me
he's just so terrified I I dared him to
take h7 and he didn't do it he just
didn't do it I can't believe it now
we'll never know what might wreck works
yeah
he changes the trick team eh it was not
the trick I was gonna take this bishop
and then take this Knight and then play
tricky eight and then I take c3 and then
your he ate and then the Queen's pinned
to the King that was my big trick oh my
god he attacks my h7 pawn I hate him how
dare he
I don't I don't want to play a five I
just want to play aged six and live look
my best happy life let's take all the
stuff rook e8 looks good
but you know that wasn't my move seems
unfair I've done your suggestions before
seems good I think I'm winning a piece
i all miked up Mac he's all pinned up
seems bad this one this one this one why
don't that fight why not this one or
that oh yeah I love it
winning a queen seems pretty good white
or science all right gaining some rating
points yeah
I'm still disappointed you didn't take
on h7 them so once again everybody the
f3 nimza wins by force for white but
only when I'm playing it you can't play
it against me that's just unfair oh it's
5 - this could be it oh no this one's
casual send us read it challenges
created show that's what we're
and just like that see I I grew up
playing play chess and then when that
went away I love to when I was in Europe
I moved to just 2409 when I came here
everybody was on chance calm so I moved
to dad not everybody these days are
doing glitch si yeah we move around I I
had a much simpler internet chess career
I started off on the free internet chess
server fi CS I don't know if you've ever
played there fix used to be a big bug
house server I think it's still kind of
is that's where all the bug house
professionals would go for chess and
then eventually we begged my parents
enough got an ICC membership that was
good oh I see yeah ICC was great the
Russians used this yeah it's it was a
big like training what's on there big
Russian server and then eventually I
just switched on over to the whole
league chess chess calm people I
remember so many stories that I've heard
like back in the days before my days
mm-hmm
they're like people would actually meet
and chat on ICC or play chess and they
would actually grow room gets the
romantic and oh I heard a lot of
interesting nice stories like got any
favorite just dating apps dorsa
yeah let's make one will do it I think
that live one is called Olympia they're
just dating a live one that's two weeks
ago there ah yeah I'm sure there's
there's plenty of plenty of Olympiad
stories to get to go around yeah so many
so many players from so many countries
all together
I like castling it's it's a really
powerful move you know it's move the
king and the rook at the same time
it's honestly incredible I don't know
how I don't know how it's allowed I
remember when I went the first like
chest training lesson that I had they
wanted to evaluate me and knew all the
moves like shorts cast off yeah for long
castle I thought the King comes to be
one it's a trick I thought it makes more
sense the Kings get safer then it'd just
be too powerful all right all right
g4 h4 h5 Bishop h6 type stuff didn't
know about this play the people how
often does it happen how often doesn't
happen I think the UH yes so so it's
once a week for our Grand Master in
resident but I think you know when we
don't have a lot going on sometimes just
the staff comes out to play the people
all right
yeah whenever whenever we have the time
so if you're interested in playing some
of the staff members of the st. Louis
chess club keep your eyes peeled I don't
know if there's a full schedule for it
or not
but will be will be about I mean the
tournaments is really hard to do any
kind of streaming's
and the tournament it's uh it's very
true and our tournament season is just
around the corner again we've got the
Karen's Cup coming up just in February
and I think in March well we might be
having some spring chess classic stuff
going on pretty soon yeah spring chess
classic in March you less championships
in April got the normal Krong Dishman
and we've got a tournament every month
oh my god this is gonna be crazy
this is gonna be crazy
h5 this other g5 then like at 5-4 f5
looks very nice but in fact with g5 9 is
5 then if I play f4 there is this Knight
g4 don't know how I feel about this g5
move yeah I think I like maybe it's a
stage 3 keep it simple you know you're
threatening f4 yep there's never any
Knight g4 business again surprisingly I
did have similar positions and Panem's
how'd you do a penance by the way I well
I was playing on our first time ever a
girls team yes
surprisingly they didn't actually face
any girls yeah that'll happen
I guess but from next Pan Am's they're
supposed to be like all-female Panem's
happening at the same time so I don't
really know that and it's supposed to be
like a two-player team yeah no they're
uh I think they're making some changes
to encourage more uh scholarship for
women yes yeah we did I was back in like
summer fall when I was talking to
Jennifer shadi I was like maybe they're
for Final Four there could be like board
for women you know yes this rate I mean
as soon as long as my team has twenty
six hundreds and all the teams have
hundred six hundred how they were gonna
get to play soo before looks tempting I
know looks very very tempting I'm
tempted good but therefore with ePHI
over up for the g5 okay Nikki five one
let's do have to take c6 first which I
don't know if yes something I'm
interested maybe just Knight d5 sure
look at g5 in the night d5
maybe chief at the effort yeah I think
it's time it's time
so the downside f5 is you always give up
this 'if I've square but I don't think
it matters a great deal in this case
first huh if Bishop d4 I guess you have
to play rook takes yes you know I
wouldn't say it's awkward I think it's
fine fine I see six seven they're
putting maybe something I know I think
it's fine
just f5 it's killer it's killer
hopefully these kind of attacks always
gonna scare me huddle
what if black manages to pull something
off a little yeah things like Bishop c4
could be a problem for black I this move
seems a little strange looks good enough
to me even there on the official I love
checks make you feel strong thank you I
think we are streaming until 4:30 p.m.
critic student if the math works out oh
my god
I looked away for a second and now you
have a piece it's incredible
next my next target is this lonely guy
over here dream bigger let's just get
that king
my name is Mike Queen dusk it's here the
king is also abuse ah it's all true
weena five Queen h5 looking dangerous I
mean I'll take it
looks like checkmate
Kinji 7:26 is close enough right
alright let's find somebody good find
somebody good well I'll Ross the door
said he wants us to play him but I don't
think we should cave just pick your
favorite let's keep it moving sure it's
three up do you want to try hand and
brain what hand and brain are you
familiar I say a piece and then you have
to choose the square the piece game you
don't know hand in brain it's a classic
[Music]
yeah chest what do you think about the
Tata Steel Masters Tournament who is
going to win is through just still like
winning or something oh he lost disaster
I have no idea what the current
standings in that tournament are the
world champion is always a favorite as
is what can you do this is a dangerous
that's what I was going for
I've seen better chest positions for
what I've seen worse ones too though
that if you're doing that bad
it's gone forever yeah
trying to pull some stuff off they don't
have the greatest of starts in Catholic
we inside maybe try and try and kill him
go on for it might end up getting hurt
though more than this yeah I don't know
who's who's more unsafe after castling
saying yeah
oh you can't prepare well yeah I started
with this one and then Perry came in
with the coffee and so then I just
appeared there's magic to this out of
thin air once I ran out of the coffee
Bishop takes I don't know about that one
I don't know about these trains I think
these are good traits for you well the
chef's prefer to self keep my pieces
yeah but this age pawn now looks unsafe
I think it's time yeah it's now or never
this is what you're talking about yes
sir it's time the king must go
57 is the safest move but then there's
like this nasty of course there's always
the snaky six move but oh I don't know
what this move is yeah f4 maybe I might
have played Ricky one just just for just
I guess 97 it's required now 94 can you
can you capture capture a piece yeah you
can you can fix some puns maybe and then
there's a check and a take on g5 guess
there's h5 I don't know what bunch of
checks okay that's one oh no more checks
unfortunate a small bunch
I mean least of all I can
you think you saw a video I did on
Larsen's opening a couple of years ago
do I rate him as GM I don't understand
that question yes
final answer okay I'm doing some funky
stuff Rabanne here take six right well
now you don't but you did Rick page for
maybe go fast win game now we're baiting
him in the 93 so I play rook e1 and then
okay he didn't fall for it
better positions
it's probably a good thing if this was
the best position you've ever had in
your life you would have some serious
problems check I love checks ah hunt
Oh expected he's super dead all of a
sudden
Wow why is it go so fast
maybe this was the plan all along for
Maidan 194 ago I forgot I had them fast
not if I check in 97 just cuz it's funny
or not yes
coming up
I think it's pretty live time you gotta
go you gotta go
this guy's too fast you gotta go yeah
give checks go fast
not fast enough I thought it was faster
he was fast
thank you all right
who do we want next I want a funny name
Johnny one all right that's fine I know
this guy it's Isaac do you know Isaac
sure it's I'm better at the faces but
yes he's like Jonathan but like with a
beard anyways
why is he drunk Oh cuz yeah yeah
question for him really see I'm playing
funky stuff better
funky I've never understood this opening
me neither I just easy to play
yeah you just like you push the pawns
because either Czech military's not do
be something somewhere hopefully at some
point
and just bring all the pieces over give
checkmate
chess is easy you would think so
h4 h5 goal killer alright go just long
castle yeah who has time for castling
just just go get checkmate every move
you spend castling some of not spent I'm
gonna make checkmate see now that's not
a thing I should play that fun forgot
about time h5 that's powerful you're
winning if you say so you're winning
look at how powerful this is can't
believe how unbelievably powerful
White's position is oh my god wow that's
that's a lot of games you guys please
yeah as a challenges a lot ah this is
the trick the name is cool so people
accept Wow free pawn deep stuff where no
no way just just I just want to take
this week maybe maybe maybe II takes and
then there's sufficient be fun no Bishop
d5
checkmate maybe he takes and there's a
bishop d5 yeah take it take it back take
it back guys like take our pawn oh let's
just rather unfortunate isn't it you
could but you don't really have to do
yeah that's just a cup for just keep it
rolling well I'm just playing our Bishop
Queen uh yeah Queen gotta be the Queen
no that's disgusting it's just chess is
awful
even awful awful things - Isaac you did
yeah yeah really
okay is it finally time to do this stuff
I think so just older a particularly
taste out of five don't get fourths I'm
not so worrying about an F but if you
are then I respect it
you know no man left behind all that
yeah or maybe you should play Knight e4
and just give him everything he ever
wanted okay
oh yeah maybe now you should play Knight
e4 if he takes it upon mighty for those
are knock this guy's lawn there's a
queen e5 whoopsie dad who cares
guys you check your license so I'll
check queen g6 called the day
looks like checkmate hopefully there's
an interesting question
at which point in your chest career was
chest the most fun for you
thanks Paul Sir Isaac watch there's a
draw so do you guys usually accept your
psyche when chess was most fun question
I mean it's kind of fun now yeah I'm
having a good time yeah like I feel like
when you're hunting down norms and
you're so stressed over like I'm kind of
like point zero point like zero six
points of something to cross this cross
that yeah like that's very very
stressful can't relate never scored a
norm in my life those are really really
stressful
I believe it so not when you're trying
to get the title yeah I think after you
have the title and you have a good
feeling of where you stand in your chest
like what are you what's your good ads
with you're not so good at then you know
to kind of avoid what you're not that
hard to yeah I feel like as soon as you
know your style that just should become
more fun I like to chest when I was a
beginner in fifth grade cuz I would play
high schoolers and feel very very
powerful okay finally what funny names
critic students been in this chat hello
I like him he seems he seems like a
stand-up guy yeah there's nothing but
nice things
actually seems like all he does is ask
questions fair enough I like questions
my g6 again slightly different this time
well you told everybody what to do how
did you guys learn chess well I was
taught by my parents
I made you when I was very young and
then I joined my school just a funny
story in fifth grade funny story so my
parents homeschooled me when I was boat
so my mom and dad taught me how to read
and write when I was like one so I
finished first grade when I was to forge
greater than a house for and I wanted to
go sit in fifth grade as a five-year-old
mm-hmm
my lovely governments didn't have
protocols or anything that's what lets
me skip any grades just you smile thank
you stuff they were like ah just feel up
for time as something so that's what my
parents did I just I just time with
Jessa and a bunch of other stuff but
yeah yeah I had more more standard
childhood learn to speak somewhere
around age 1 to 2 instead of finishing
grades in school and now I could writes
before I could walk
good right before you can walk that's
where I started walking I was like yeah
I did things in the correct order I went
backwards
my parents were teaching my sister chess
and then I demanded to be taught and
then my sister quit your sister start
learning just before you did because she
was four years older than me oh she
still is it's always weird named or
funny names they get the most attention
that's just the way it is in life Bobby
Madden you got to be interesting if you
want attention I'm not so afraid I am
nah
yeah you only shy only she's got no
light squares take the night no I want
to take and play Bishop f5 and then I'm
gonna Carol Kahn and I love the
caro-kann it's such a good care of Kahn
though hi I see that now only we could
play c6 oh thank god now it's really a
Carol how do you both feel about playing
Fischer random not a huge fishery no fan
actually I don't know about yourself
depends what I'm playing for what you're
playing for
okay I mean it's fun to play yeah and if
I'm playing someone who just wants to
play a Fischer random because they know
I suck at it
you know personally I like normal chests
and I like the variants that are nothing
like chess but these variants that are
almost chess but you know just like just
not quite it's like yeah we'll put the
rook over here instead and then it's and
then it's really just the same I want
this Queen b6 final answer I know I want
this like it's night on e6 maybe I
believe it
maybe a bishop efore move is called more
maybe I hope the age come on board I
like it seems responsible the problem is
about sometimes like Lu Bishop before if
something happens then it's like forever
forever ever all right I love it
it's a blonde their own yeah yeah I mean
I'll take the I'll take the glory I'll
take the take the blame
that's what I'm here for
so what if this guy just plays like
Bishop f2 or something what are we doing
my deaf five night at five
maybe having that play you playing out
of five I don't know I don't think you
should have taken I didn't like thanks
cuz now 95 seems really really powerful
95 if you're forking you you're taking
d4 you're doing everything hey free pawn
you want Queen rook let's just do rook
that's funny I'm a firm believer of
freedom of choice yeah
I'm a friendly drop in chess comedy you
know play the funniest move so please
all work out funniest most yeah I'm not
afraid of my f7 pawn strong he's a
strong guy okay how do you win material
where's where is the tactic he's a
tactic somewhere I don't know where I'm
looking for it I don't see it
how about Queen C sound even better here
hey beef I love it let's do that most
are really awkward
we file I guess we're committed
no it looks great
you can take all our kings like pawns it
doesn't matter just by King h8 you're
safe nothing to worry about
he's very brave I've been far more
checkmated some of my best wins look
somewhat like this where it's in the
caro-kann and there's just like a pawn
on h7 like just a white pawn on h7 and I
have no dark square Bishop and I'm just
chillin whoa
who is she me yeah who are you this is
of course international master Dorset
erection
our current international master in
residence at Sigma are you crying
we need seven yeah you take it where you
want these seven are ups I like f6 okay
I want to take rooks sitting on a one
you wanted me to be easy so g6 i likey
6k r that I don't care that pawn on e6
is coming to e7 and that's just no fun I
just go just move ah that is correct I
keep forgetting to move yeah I'll just
sit here and tell you to make chess
moves that'll be my role just like
screaming faster go yes nasty nasty
pawns come for it soon enough thank you
I think that guy queen g4 easy no King
f7 you're safe you're so safe yeah
you're so safe they're very safe this is
the safest King I've ever said in my
life oh my god absolutely nothing to
worry about
we have three check things and now it's
all safe what's life without risk happy
life save life boring life resigns wow I
definitely would have tried to win this
game on time ha Kramnik student okay
there's somebody who's clout the casual
someone is called a casual player yeah
that's a pretty good one
maybe they canceled the challenge so
this Ghormeh sabzi is a Persian dish a
Persian dish yeah oh this guy's scary
though
he's 1,500 question mark trust those
people that means he's never played a
rated game on this website before this
guy could be magnus carlsen for all we
know you know one time I was sitting
right there
some random account challenged me I had
never played a rate of Blitz game before
but it had like a 2900 crazy house
rating I was very confused about how
this person had such a high crazy-house
rating and so like I didn't think the
game very seriously I played like you
know II four and got into an IED Orff
and I play d4 and so I had no idea what
I was doing the entire time and I just
got crushed and then three months later
Wesley so comes to the chess club he
sees me he's like ah I played you and
I'm like you did what's like yeah
unleash yes it's like when you were
doing the the stream thing and I sent
you a challenge so I went back to find
the game and sure enough I was Wesley so
so this guy this guy could be Perugia
for all we know it could be anybody you
never know with these 1,500 question
mark people very business Bruges just a
fast chess player are you gonna do show
yourself who are you son that song as a
picture
yeah
how is 94 thank you
[Music]
yeah but that's an e pawn for a seat
Potter he pawns are better than sea
funds I maintain this belief all right
so it's not fair and that takes this
invest either Magnus loves gourmet ship
how do you say this dish Ghormeh sabzi
you need to say yeah buy it that's you
you can Ghormeh sabzi you're saying it
that but that's you're saying it is
gates oh yeah
guy you close yeah yeah your bishops
attacked go look out go fast
let's go go go anyways
Magnus loves this Iranian dish good
they're just saying thanks that's what
they do it's really good okay three I
don't know how I feel about that move
d5 I don't know how I feel about it
maybe it's good let's bring out the big
guys looks powerful Thanks as long as
it's not a blonde there those dolls
happen more often than you would like oh
god your ex attacked
what are you gonna do my god
I forgot to take the bomb faster what if
it's what if it gets to fund it
oh my god then I'll feel really bad
please don't defend your phone sometimes
I want to develop but I forgot that I'm
attacking it happens oh thank goodness
really really worried he was gonna
defend that pawn Joe maybe it's getting
this Queen trade in no no what are you
gonna do how do you stop it he's daring
you to do some sacrifices I like the
move Bishop g4 rg6 but then Queen h4 and
its trading Queens I want to play Bishop
g4 and then I want to play d5 I'm gonna
play trick takes g3 this is my big game
plan what do you want to play d5 there's
25 and look at 5 maybe I don't know you
like you made it well I think there's
two rocks on the board
alright let's say bye-bye to this guy
first
wait Louie okay what what if you move
the rook out of the way and then play
Bishop f3 and then play checkmate that's
what I was thinking you okay I think I
like that plan and plus he can play rock
out force is the funniest
oh that was good I mean you played funny
moves that's what you have to do thank
you
how do you learn to recognize chest
squares instantly I have to think about
where c3 is from the black side like
really like I did cry was really fun
well you know I mean it paid off so I
guess tank I should thank him so to
answer your question Jim Morrison find
someone will scream at you to the point
of Tears and then maybe you will learn
the squares that looks like checkmate
[Music]
just every time you sort of square wrong
you just also if I couldn't like solve
he would keep telling me I'll never be
anything in life phobia I'll end up like
you know living a ditch that's what you
got to do that's a tough world out there
and then it wasn't just death Coast when
I was growing up one of the coaches told
me like I'm too pretty yeah I should go
to Hollywood I just don't use my brain
and I was like I want to use my brain
you know it's and he bet me that I'm my
racing would never across the year would
never cross the year wow I gotta use
that one that's that's that's a good one
[Laughter]
feel like you've had a more successful
chest Korea than me but maybe I've had a
happier one from these toys I what about
this stupid nicknames guy we've been
talking about him for hours yeah and I
would keep going back to him I don't
know why you gotta you gotta be tough I
guess
I was hoping that dank move worked what
I don't know I don't know which movie is
referring to hmm uh he's somebody
YouTube chat
his name's Leo Narborough da Vinci this
works
Catalan d5 there's this like Bishop
before I hate it I hate it it doesn't
make sense to me I understand it let's
go with this one I love it I don't
I usually play the mainlines these days
Bishop e7 castles King side against
Queen c2 I've been playing this b6 thing
I love it their buns were like 96 repeat
b5 s here I like developing pieces this
seems like not the most accurate move
order from the white player also the
black player you up for check sure I
love giving Shaq Jack look I did it
again
have you played around with the Black
Lion
never in my life then I learned with the
Black Lion it's this like a 5d6 thing
and then you play like I ate six and g5
that's ridiculous it's ridiculous
opening yeah alright what do we want
take em clean v6 its playable I don't
know just because you said it okay all
right well it's all on me once again
that's always
maybe 95 there's something haskell no
yeah it's just castle let's get out of
there
runaway v6 not even covered in avarice
waitest book on the Catalan sorry I
probably misspoke I meant you take on c4
Queen c2 and then b6 I don't know if I
said that correctly it might not be
covered but there's some some games in
the recent years we've how you find drew
Aronian in that lion maybe Castle I
should have done some like a six people
I love castling know it's just it's
somehow but sometimes in Catalan the
castle means you have to give back the
palm maybe sometimes you can actually
fly towards I'm a giver
you know I mean take my pond it's fun I
don't I like taking the ponds I just
don't like keeping them a six look
strong gonna be careful maybe you take
on d2 first cuz otherwise your Bishop is
but if Bishop before takes game you can
you play like that I don't know there's
like a king of this just seems simple
free pawn
okay should be something can you develop
your bishop I don't know too early give
it another 10 moves maybe yeah see 1695
I went 95 I think I just love shoving
stuff on this diagonal before it's too
late
see six weeks of threats that's all I
can I see formwork talking this guy eat
six III I don't know I don't know why
you want to oh you want to attack F - I
see you just said that out loud
I was asleep before why not
c6 making a threat I love it I love
making threats
maybe he'll miss it and then we could
win a piece sure
you didn't miss it I'm winning a piece
no we're not but now maybe you can play
one of your moves like new g4 but then
probably still III or Queen f3 or
something I really wanna be able to play
like free this guy mm-hmm
but I don't think it works efore just
III
it's difficult it's a difficult to
opening this can rain maybe put this
Queen back on f6 yeah and I'm trying to
do 95 maybe bring the night f3 or
something
I was it all seems okay too good to be
true
same time is attacked devastating
what if Knight d6 I guess we have the
knight f5
cuz it's time to bring out the bishop Oh
God alright I'm on board your pawn is
attacked and I'm a little afraid I gotta
push it okay push it then let's do it do
I have to push it way faster 96 it still
seems like a chess move maybe there's
Rick d8 now though I don't know
something seems to have gone wrong here
well I may have this look Queenie's
Dixon maybe maybe I can dream I'm
dreaming
Jaffar what's to be done cry g4 Bishop
e6 maybe you're gonna play f5 like a
maniac king h2 Witcher crew on DS left
or we can just label Sub G season 5 but
this go fast okay yeah I don't know
about this one something something feels
bad thanks for bad oh my god didn't they
create some stuff about our queen and
king being on the same diagonal I'm very
afraid I feel like I'm always the one
who's not afraid but now all of a sudden
you seem quite fearless I'm out of
options it's not courage ouchie Queen g5
to h5 so you can give a check but this
you can move not afraid
outta there
maybe Bishop h5 Bishop f3 just got to go
fast go fast when again let's do it what
a minute I really believe in that chance
this year a minute maybe Misha page
powerful moves invading your invading
Mary Queen is fine this is checkmate
this is checkmate if I've ever seen
check ah for everybody involved in ig8
oh that moves checkups now we're made it
that's uh sad check couldn't stop myself
I I mean I'm always on board for playing
any in all checks yeah stupid nicknames
very powerful chess player who saw it
coming alright let's play somebody bad
it's more fun just like dangerous
haircut
sir you're in charge here I am whatever
you want so it's always just along for
the ride
you for a nice haircut is not connected
to the game it's rather unfortunate
maybe he's coming maybe he'll never come
oh there he is
but now how will he respond to e4 we'll
never know
maybe we never will know he's really
thinking we might have to give up on him
pretty soon I don't know all right
it's a shame was a funny haircut was too
dangerous it's petrified board universe
where he's like down there he's pretty
good though could play let's see I don't
know does that Bangor fine gold I don't
know just I'm saying this name and it
looks like been fine gold with no vowels
but maybe it's other words and said oh
he's offered to rematch he's back i I
say we give him a second chance it's all
part of his scheme he's too tricky come
on let's play a move there he goes he 45
maybe we'll play the Black Lion you
never know if I know that what's what is
it
I really don't fully remember I think
you just play like a Philidor and then
all of a sudden from the reason you play
g5 this is my understanding of the black
line like II five d6 Bishop e7 and then
h6 and she fight or something
don't you like their real names too like
in chess Tommy you could actually like
see I mean if you want to you can see
who is who what's the who's the guy
yes sometimes they do put the name on
the chest as well but you have to go to
that profile I think dangerous haircut
taking his time on roof three it's an
important one a lot of decisions to be
made we play Knight c3 when we play
Bishop b5 really play Bishop c4 really
play d4 my god
honestly I don't know how people ever
make a third though there's just so many
choices and he's disconnected maybe
giving dangerous haircut a second chance
was a mistake after all um a3 my god it
was worth it it was worth the way honest
I'm blown away
a3 not what I saw coming okay so I have
two options in my mind I can either do
that cute like this excuse ago all right
yeah try to open up the center and go
crazy what I want to see let's open the
center let's go so this is something I
think you can keep in mind whenever your
opponent plays some strange moves in
these b4 b5 openings when they don't
control the center maybe you can take
advantage and push let's see like we
tell all these things and when somebody
plays d4 side all right so now you play
like matter of six you play a six you
don't talk you don't look at the center
you feel like you were ten mohs without
putting anything in center yes okay I'm
afraid our pawn is way attacked oh my
god so attacked I think you could seems
like a reasonable thing to do
I'm not so bothered by something taking
rc6 night
are you bothered yeah I'm not so
bothered what up this up to you for
Bishop g4 maybe its tree could be done
you have to take could also play Queen
f6 here after 95 and maybe try into
checkmate our opponent your hopeful
maybe you could play Queen g5 96 Queen B
5-4 what if Queen d4 what Queen diva
nice this extent well oh you want to
just I wanna get prettier yeah and I
want to attack a Jeep on a lot of
nowhere here you know and now he's gonna
play d4 and I'm gonna feel very foolish
when G - yeah you ruined my my trick
now he's gonna play d4 and I'll feel
very foolish are you list are you
listening we'll never know when is your
next over the board event dorsa and
Caleb it's nice of them to include me in
these questions when is your next over
the board events do you know well for
sure I'm playing the collegiate rapid
and blitz championship that's in March
right here at SLU right it was last year
maybe not right here at SLU but
definitely gonna be playing in March
yeah any other big plans big events
gonna travel anywhere anytime soon so
the thing is I have three laps this
semester organic chemistry lab Tuesdays
8 a.m.
oh God you took her piece
and bumped into other labs that I have
to survive over like plan killers school
stuff
this is the last semester that's going
to be horrifyingly tough after death it
gets slightly better what if we played
it we again g5 attacking that we
consistent with your plans now if
castles there was Bishop age three
Bishop F we should not Bishop f3 it won
the game right where are you going with
your bishop I'm sorry Bishop g4 and I
was I was looking at the f3 square
this Queen is just trapped yeah I guess
there's a d4 or a d3 to try and keep
things alive I think it'd be really
funny to see him play d3 though and then
maybe we can attack ah except to point I
don't know
my next over the board tournament it's
probably going to be in February I'm
going to play the US Amateur team East
is the plan East East Way over there
there's a ghost there's a West there is
a central because ok so we did like a
meet need the best collegiate
championship last semester but that was
out there in Mizzou yeah the inaugural
Midwest from what I understood they have
a something in Texas that they're also
required to play but it's not only once
a year it's like a few times a year
yeah it's not yeah I was talking to some
of the take the stock Texas Tech people
mm-hm and they were telling me you have
not wait you did I always mix this
thing's list occurs with all the
russian-ukrainian speakers that sounds
right that sounds like Texas Tech
I like our chances in this this specific
game chess
I think this might be our last one for
the stream actually I don't know we've
crossed for 3005 took no time at all
here we are
anything else on the chat oh nothing
really nothing really
so I got a question I can't play 26 and
eat the piece do you want that or you
want something like blue fifty three or
negative six
let's see I like Knight f6 why don't you
eat the piece because I want to
checkmate the King it always feels
better if you checkmate the King when
there are more pieces on the board if
you can't take pieces his castle is
legal no no rook check who cares about
that night on that not on b3 is not it's
never gonna be a part of this chess game
ever again
can we suck a full rook I would love to
sacrifice my room for free I want no
more pieces you have your wild ride very
boring chess right why thank you
boring like what's the point if you're
just gonna win messes and all those fun
stuff you know like you play like snake
you go around your path whatever
whatever thank you okay
this was pretty fun yeah uh some some
good games today I think the only person
who took us out was stupid nicknames we
lost two stupid nicknames and that was
that
well I'm very exciting news for those
people on the YouTube channel still if
you enjoyed this show there is another
livestream going on in an hour and a
half I'm going to be teaching a class
called the road to 2000s so if you're
interested stick around
like I said starting at 6 p.m. that's
when it'll be going on endorsing any any
shows that you're a part of coming up
any classes you want tomorrow yeah oh
yeah this year I started teaching the
chess on psychology so far two lessons
on so I don't think yesterday was a
strange no no no let's see any cameras
well probably yeah but yeah that's
pretty fun so chess in psychologist a
success 30 you sure to check that one
out I think that's it for us today on
play the people thank you all so much
for joining us giving us some good chess
games and we'll catch you next time
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you